started to do something my brother did
to me that i hated i put vaseline in
basically every pocket that he had
jacket pocket pant pocket anything oh
that will drive you slowly crazy right
and i could hear him go oh i'm gonna
bite you so hard the vaseline in the
pockets man one pocket two pocket three
pocket four dr seuss rhyme every pocket
i reached into had vaseline in it it was
just so enraging my wife calls me into
the bedroom excuse me you come in here i
go short and i look on the mirror
and written in vaseline
on the mirror
i can't wait to fight you
and she goes
you happy with yourself and i go yeah
actually i'm pretty happy i go he just
wrote a death wish with vaseline he's
read this now after i did that i went
and like just got ready for war you
never get into a room you get really
angry you just start doing push-ups in
the middle of your room for no reason
whatsoever that was me i'm just sitting
there i'm blasting music i have a
bandana on i am ready we're at day five
and he's ready to snap so i do the thing
to him that my brothers did to me that
made me snap the quickest they used to
lock me in my bath
oh yeah for hours
now i wasn't going to lock him in for
hours just like an hour and a half
something he's in the bathroom i take
some rope and i tied to the handle i
just sit and i wait
and i hear the toilet flush
and then i just hear the door handle
and i get a text
i'm locked in the bathroom
so i sent him a text back
i know
and then it was just like in a horror
movie all from the inside of the
bathroom all i heard is are you out
there
obviously at this point i am losing my
absolute mind in this game because i'm
not one for mental warfare he goes you
let me out of here right now i'll break
the door down
and i pick up my phone i'm like break it
down has anyone in here ever seen
someone try to break down the door
some funny [ __ ] the first time i saw it
i was in college and my buddy was like
i'm beating the [ __ ] out of this guy and
i go let's go and he goes to his house
and the door was locked and he was like
i'm breaking in i go break it and my
buddy went
and his lip went
because it's a [ __ ] door everybody
that's why they put it up there so you
can't walk in and out all willy nilly
if you think you can break down a door
you watch too much law and order that's
all i'm saying
so he goes i'm gonna break it down and
the reason i have my camera up guys is
because i'm gonna film it because i
already have my wife and i have a video
that's seven and a half minutes long of
dumb [ __ ] that he's done that we're
gonna play at his wedding
there's nothing you could do that could
embarrass me at any point in my life
anymore at this time i can't wait to see
that video
i'm really excited actually so i have it
up like this right
and i'm ready because i know what's
going to happen he goes i'm breaking it
down i go do it and he goes one
two
three three and all i hear is
silence
it's quiet for like two three minutes
he goes i'm pretty sure this is child
abuse
pretty sure it was and still is and i
said yeah which part he was like dig all
of it
silence for like another three minutes
then he said something that made me
laugh so hard i had to leave the room
i just hear from the bathroom
i'm hungry
i've been in there for like 20 minutes
man it was the morning i wanted
breakfast dad dad listen if you crack
the door and slip in a sandwich
i promise not to try to get out i'm like
oh [ __ ] stockholm syndrome is sitting
anyway this dude
negotiating with his captors and stuff
you know
i go i can't do that man he was like oh
and this is when i knew he was ready to
fight i just heard him starting to
mumble to himself
[Music]
what was that face you made that was
really strange
and then he said this he goes well when
i get out of here i'm just gonna shake
them and i was like
[ __ ] i've never been so mad where i'm
like i'm just gonna shake a [ __ ] out of
that
i was like oh he's ready to fight like
are you ready to come out man he goes
yeah i'm ready
and i go okay and i open the door you've
never seen a bull come out of a shoot at
a rodeo where all their muscles are
moving at once and he's coming out he's
like i'm gonna find you so hard do any
of you know what it's like to just be
walking down the street and just from a
passing car window like a drive-by i'm
gonna fight you so hard
and are you ready because i'm ready i go
let's go because not yet i gotta change
into my fight clothes i'm like i'm rocky
right remember i'm prepared for this
i go out on the hallway and i see my
wife beth and she's like listen you sure
you still want to fight him i go he just
he was just talking about shaking
somebody so he's going to fight somebody
today so
might as well be me and she said this is
nothing good is going to come out of
this i really think it's a bad idea and
i said what did i tell you about that
i'll let you know when i have a bad idea
you saying
to mom i'll let you know when i have a
bad idea in itself is a terrible idea
and she was like
okay and i go just do me a favor
just put my phone in the window because
when i pin him that's going to be the
end of the wedding video like that's a
good way to go out
wedding video over me pinning him right
so i walk outside and when i walk
outside guys i'm pretty happy with
myself for a couple of reasons one i
didn't have to get as violent
as my dad did to get him this mad right
and two nobody in here remembers the
stories about when you were a kid how
many times your mom cut the crust off
your sandwich you don't remember the
nice stuff
you're like you remember when [ __ ]
tommy fell off the roof do you know what
i mean those are the stories you tell
and i know this is a story he's gonna
tell and then he comes busting
out of the house by the way you wanna
know what his fight clothes were
jean shorts
no shirt and a bandana
i was like where are you going coachella
i called my uncle adam his oldest
brother i said hey man i'm gonna fight
dad soon what did you wear when you used
to pick on him when he gave me this
outfit this is where my first like
psychological warfare really came in now
it's gonna be like ptsd when i walk out
he's gonna think wow wait is he gonna
beat me in the same clothes that my
brother used to beat me up in i'm just
trying to play games right now and he
comes running at me throws a punch i
duck and i throw him over my hip and bam
he lands on his back
you guys know that noise oh
[Music]
when all the air just uh
and i'm like oh i got a couple minutes
the wind has been knocked out of him and
the first time the wind gets knocked out
of you you think you're dying right that
feeling is the worst feeling of all time
when you land straight on your back you
never feel like you're going to breathe
the same ever again i was a huge
wrestling fan
huge randy the macho man savage fan
so i started to walk around and i'm like
oh yeah the macho man
i'm looking in the window at the camera
like
macho man what decade is that from oh
yeah year old snap into a nursing home
and then i get a couple more seconds i'm
gonna come off the top rope and i'm
gonna jump on him pull his leg up pin
him end of the wedding video perfect
right so i go what you gonna do
when the macho man lands on you
i go to push and when i push his leg
slipped when this leg slipped a disc
popped in my back
him and i landed right on him and i
knocked the wind out of him again
and he's like get off of me get off of
me and i was like get out from under me
get out from under me
and we're both laying there like a
couple of wet mops in the front yard huh
30 seconds later he gets out from under
me walks inside and i'm laying in the
front
just laying there probably for like 10
minutes there was no real pin
and you were hurt worse than i was i'm
gonna go ahead and call that a draw when
i walked inside of sitting in the
kitchen just leaning up against the
counter drinking some water and my mom
comes in and she goes fight over i think
so where's your dad still outside in the
front yard she went out to go check on
him the front door opens and i see two
feet walking out to me and
i recognize sophie those are my wives
she walks out and she leans over me just
like this and she goes
how do you think that went
i said i think it went pretty well
and she said did it
i said i won she goes did you
she said all i know is that he's inside
drinking water and you're still laying
out here with your face in the dirt
he looks like the winner i go yeah but
we're gonna cut the video off way before
that nobody's ever gonna see that [ __ ]
and i knew why she came out
she came out to tell me
that she was right and i was wrong and
she was
and i was gonna let i told her right off
the front i said look i know you were
right i was wrong and i'm so sorry and i
am the adult and he is the child and i
really just need to keep that in mind
like
this is how you parent and we're parent
together and i'm sorry we didn't do this
together and i should have listened to
you
but thank you very much for coming out
to help me in and she said i didn't come
out here to help you with it
i came out here to tell you that the
camera is still running in the window
and i think i'm going to start a little
video of my own
because the sprinklers are set to come
on in three minutes
and as she's walking away i go babe i
don't think that's a good idea she turns
to me and she goes i'll let you know
when i have a bad idea
the way my mom said i'll let you know
and i have a bad idea when she walked in
the house
it's almost like she knew exactly how
this whole situation was going to play
out from day one she's way smarter than
both of us that's it everybody i hope
you all enjoyed the video that's one of
the craziest stories from my childhood
and growing up with a comedian of a dad
if you guys like the content and want to
see more ridiculous stories from my life
go and hit the like button throw a
comment down there
subscribe and make sure you turn those
notifications on and thank you guys
again so much for coming and tuning in
and i hope you guys have a great day
we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]